euro disney land est né en tout cas
l'acte a été signé ce matin par le
premier ministre et le président de la
walt disney productions michael eisner
ce parc sera donc située à une
quarantaine de kilomètres à l'est de
paris a marre de la vallée nous
reviendrons dans un instant sur
l'historique du projet est ce qu'il va
développer et puis sur la colère des
forains aussi qui se sente menacé mais
qui ont en partie obtenu satisfaction en
satisfaction de jacques chirac ce matin
au moment de la signature d'ailleurs
alors l'ouverture du parc est prévu pour
1992 et ce sera là le premier centre de
loisirs de ce genre en europe
il a fallu près de deux années de
travail et de négociations christophe
martet un dossier volumineux pour un
accord original
c'est la première fois en effet que les
pouvoirs publics signe un contrat
d'équipement avec une entreprise privée
un accord obtenu après 15 mois de
négociations difficiles entre français
et américains
tout commence en décembre 85 ans le site
de marne-la-vallée en concurrence avec
barcelone est retenu pour l'implantation
d'un euro disneyland le 18 décembre
laurent fabius signent un protocole
d'accord avec le pdg de disney le
premier ministre de l'époque souhaite
boucler le projet en trois mois
c'est compter sans l'appétit des
américains la disney company ne laisse
rien au hasard
demande et obtient toujours plus de la
france notamment sur le financement et
l'aménagement du parc d'attractions les
pouvoirs publics de leur côté tenons
beaucoup à ce projet créateur d'emplois
y avait des promesses qui avaient été
faites lorsque le précédent gouvernement
a avalisé les propositions qui avait été
faite par mon prédécesseur
ces propositions et promesses elles ont
été tenues ce qui était bien naturel
parce que ça faisait partie d'un
équilibre d'ensemble amené le rer à
l'entrée d'une part faire des prêts
bonifiés de la caisse des dépôts baisser
les taux le taux de la tva sur les
tickets d'entrée pour cela il a fallu un
certain nombre de décisions importantes
assez difficile à prendre pour une bonne
poignée de dollars la france accueillera
mika sur son sol ouverture prévue le
royaume enchanté d'euro disneyland en 92